HAPPENS, WE WILL HAVE BACK.
LET'S GET REACTION TO THE
McCABE ANNOUNCEMENT AND MORE
ON THE STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STANDING DIE ON THE
NORTH LAWN.
>> GOOD EVENING.
WHY ARE WIDELY EXPECTED, AS
CATHERINE MENTIONED, THAT
ANDREW MCCABE WAS GOING TO
RETIRE SOMETIME IN MARCH FOR THE
TIMING OF TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENT
APPEARED TO CATCH EVEN THE
WHITE HOUSE OFF GUARD.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE HAD NOTHING
TO SAY ABOUT THE RESIGNATION OF
THE FBI DEPUTY DIRECTOR TODAY
OTHER THAN INSISTING
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH IT.
>> WE HAVE SEEN THE NUMEROUS
REPORTS, AS ALL OF YOU HAVE.
ANY SPECIFICS I CAN TELL YOU
NONE OF THIS DECISION WAS MADE
BY THAT OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
SPEAK WITH THE PRESIDENT WAS
CERTAINLY SHUTTING NO TEARS
ABOUT ANDREW MCCABE'S DEPARTURE.
IN DECEMBER, HE TWEETED "HOW CAN
ANDREW MCCABE GIVEN $700,000 FOR
WIFE'S CAMPAIGN BY CLINTON
PUPPETS DURING INVESTIGATION."
THE TIMELINE WASN'T EXACTLY
ACCURATE BUT THE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T SEEM TO
FOLLOWING UP WITH ANOTHER TWEET.
"FBI DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND HER
McCABE IS RACING THE CLOCK TO
RETIRE WITH FULL BENEFITS.
90 DAYS TO GO?"
>> YOU SAY THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
NOT INVOLVED BUT CLEARLY THE
PRESIDENT SEEMED TO BE INVOLVED
IN A CAMPAIGN RELATIONS AGAINST
McCABE.
>> THE PRESIDENT STANDS BY HIS
PREVIOUS COMMENTS BUT IN TERMS
OF THE SITUATION TODAY, WE HAVE
WE DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
COMMENTS.
I WOULD REFER YOU TO THE FBI FOR
ANY SPECIFICS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PREPARATION
FOR THE STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS TOMORROW.
THE SPEECH WILL BREAK DOWN INTO
FIVE CATEGORIES.
JOBS AND THE ECONOMY,
INFRASTRUCTURE, IMMIGRATION,
TRADE, NATIONAL SECURITY.
THE PRESIDENT WILL THROW DOWN
THE GAUNTLET TO DEMOCRATS TO CUT
BORDER SECURITY.
>> IT'S GOT TO BE BIPARTISAN.
THE REPUBLICANS DON'T HAVE THE
VOTES TO GET IT DONE ANY OTHER
HOPEFULLY ENOUGH DEMOCRATS WILL
JOIN US SO WE CAN REALLY DO
SOMETHING GREAT FOR DACA AND
IMMIGRATION IN GENERAL.
>> ON NATIONAL SECURITY, THE
PRESIDENT WILL STRETCH THE
CRUCIAL NEED TO TURN BACK
NORTH KOREA'S NUCLEAR PROGRAM
FROM THE DEFEAT ISIS AND RAIN IN
IRAN'S BEHAVIOR.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HOSTED THE U.N.
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL LUNCH.
THEY SELL REMNANTS OF WHAT THE
REBELS.
NIKKI HALEY SHARPLY CRITICAL OF
A GRAMMY SEGMENT TONIGHT WHERE
CELEBRITIES READ FROM "FIRE AND
FURY."
IN A TWEET, HALEY RIPPED THE
SOME OF US LOVE MUSIC WITHOUT
THE POLITICS."
AFTER A NIGHT WHERE MANY ARTISTS
WORE WHITE ROSES,
HILLARY CLINTON CAME UNDER